[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
after days of deliberations jurors reach
a deadlock ladies and gentlemen the jury
it's my understanding
what this could mean for the ohio doctor
accused of patient murder plus infowars
files for bankruptcy as alex jones is
slammed with defamation lawsuits in the
sandy hook school shooting case but
first it's week two of johnny depp
versus amber heard mr death told you
that he felt the majority of his issues
with his wife had been from him using
drugs and alcohol
according to the note yes the highlights
of day four of testimony law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer at the
start of week two jurors get a closer
look into the relationship of johnny
depp and amber hurd on monday experts
testified about an incident when the tip
of deb's finger was cut off
the exes now face off in a multi-million
dollar defamation suit stemming from a
2018 washington post op-ed written by
her while depp's name was not mentioned
in the piece heard alleges she was a
victim of domestic abuse depp argues he
lost roles in both the harry potter and
pirates of the caribbean franchises
because of her accusations after that
depp filed a defamation suit against
herd to the tune of 50 million dollars
heard countersued for a hundred million
dollars on monday of this week jurors
heard the second half of the video
deposition of debt's former doctor david
kipper he detailed what happened when
the tip of dep's finger was cut off
while in australia
i went in to instruct
one of the
people with him
to look for the tip of the finger
hoping that we would be able to put it
back
was the tip of the finger found
it was found when you went into the
house did you see miss heard
yes
and how did he appear
she was
certainly upset was miss heard's face
swollen at all when you saw her
not that i was aware of him
did miss hurt have any cuts on her arms
when you saw her
not that i can recall
did you recall seeing any cuts on her
feet or any other part of her body
i can't recall
if ms heard had appeared to have been
injured is this something that you would
have documented
yes
jurors also heard video depositions from
debbie lloyd the former personal nurse
of depths she told jurors about depp's
recovery
you wrote
bandage changed and hand exercises done
at appointment with surgeon's office
per rn at surgeon's office and
occupational therapist hand is healing
well and finger has good range of motion
exercise is to be done three to five
times per day
patient is in good spirits and said he's
not smoke marijuana in three days
states he feels majority of his issues
with his wife have been
from him using drugs and alcohol
patience states he will no longer sneak
use and wants to enjoy clarity
you wrote you wrote that
yes
and these are part of your nurse's notes
yes
and mr death told you that he felt the
majority of his issues with his wife had
been from him using drugs and alcohol
according to the note yes
and mr depp wrote he will no longer
sneak use and wants to enjoy clarity
according to the document yes
what is being referred to as no longer
sneak use
i only know what's stated in my
notes
okay would it be anything other than
drugs or alcohol
i don't recall
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike corybonix and co-host
terry austin mike this trial started off
as a she said he said type of situation
but as more and more witnesses testify
how are depp's lawyers doing in coloring
heard as a certain type of person and
what type is that i think they're doing
very well and they're doing very well
because he was surrounded by
professionals when i say professionals i
mean doctors we see nurses here
and they have ethical obligations to
keep accurate notes so they're more
credible than the average person in the
sense that they're not only living up to
a person's obligation to tell the truth
but their profession makes them keep
records that need to be truthful so i
think they're gaining credibility for mr
depp with every one of these
professionals who referred to their
notes to lay out how this occurred
now terry have you heard any bit of the
cross-examination because that's where
heard may be able to piece together some
of her story in this case uh in the
cross-examinations of dr kipper or
debbie lloyd that may have helped herd's
counterclaim or do you think she's just
waiting to put on her witnesses and her
testimony
i don't think any of the
cross-examination really helped amber's
case she's going to have to rely
primarily on her own witnesses dr kipper
was the far more credible witness he was
very supportive of depp's position he's
the interns he's the addiction
specialist and while some of his answers
he did say i don't recall most of his
answers were very definitive he
basically said that there was no
violence reported he basically said he
never saw any evidence of violence so he
was very strong as far as nurse lloyd
was concerned she didn't recall anything
we may as well have just read her notes
and i think even though she did say she
didn't see violence and nobody told her
that they were violent to each other
she basically wasn't credible and i
don't think the jury is going to
appreciate her testimony yeah i
understand from a legal standpoint why
she has to say i don't recall but after
a couple hours of that i can see why
many jurors and many viewers may doze
off in that case but we'll keep eyes on
it as it continues still ahead on lawn
crime daily alex jones's company files
for bankruptcy amidst a slew of
defamation lawsuits but first we dig
deeper into the defamation suit of
johnny depp versus amber hur jesse weber
is at the fairfax county courthouse
where fans on both sides of the aisle
are making news
[Music]
welcome back we continue coverage now in
the johnny depp versus amber heard
defamation lawsuit the second week of
the lawsuit began amidst controversy
after a heard supporter is banned from
the courtroom for the remainder of the
trial law and crime network's jesse
weber joins us in fairfax virginia
explaining what happened and who eve
barlow is
hey there brian so monday began with the
continued testimony of dr david kipper
but the real drama happened on friday
when the judge banned eve barlow from
the courtroom after an interruption on
thursday now according to documents that
were obtained by long crime depp's
attorneys had filed the motion to ban
barlow and it was granted on friday you
might recall that on thursday long
crime's own angeannette levy saw barlow
escorted from the courtroom after she
was apparently on her cell phone barlow
who was seen arriving to court with her
is accused of tweeting in that courtroom
where cell phones are banned and then
misrepresenting information to her
attorneys now notably on thursday depth
witness gina deuters was dismissed by
the judge and her testimony struck from
the record after she admitted to
watching clips of the trial just before
this barlow showed hurd's attorneys a
social media post by deuters discussing
depp's separate defamation case against
the sun tabloid
that was jesse weber reporting from
fairfax county virginia rain or shine
outside the courthouse a law and crime
network correspondents have also heard
from johnny depp supporters at the start
of the trial dozens of supporters
gathered outside the courthouse with
justice for johnny signs they told
reporters they were there to support
depp at the time only one herd supporter
was seen outside the courthouse on
monday of this week law encrimes jesse
weber spoke with a woman originally from
peru who came to the courthouse with two
alpacas wearing a justice for johnny's
sign
when you hear the allegations that are
put against them you don't believe them
no not at all i mean a guy that does
what he does and how he does it it's
just not believable at all so what do
you think of amber heard
i don't want to
say um nothing bad about her but
i don't believe it okay yeah so what are
you hoping for at the end of this case
i hope he gets justice that's all
whatever the judge sees fit i just hope
that he can
he can get it yeah so you'll support him
no matter what
i mean yeah it's there's no um proof
against him really so i
yeah as long as that remains that way of
course you don't think he's ever hurt
anyone no
there were lies made about him oh yeah
totally why
it's uh
just the way that they say the way that
they phrased it it's just
i'm not sure it's just i don't believe
it really
got to be a law in crime first jessie
weber and to alpacas terry we saw that
uh gina deuters was excused and her
testimony was stricken from the record
what exactly happened there
all right so just to give you a little
background gina is depp's friend and she
was on the stand she was testifying on
behalf of deaf eve barlow is amber's
friend and she was sitting in court near
amber and she gave that note to amber's
attorney saying that gina had tweeted
about quote the trial the tweet was
actually about the london trial but the
judge interrupted gina's testimony and
basically she questioned her and asked
her if she had seen any clips of this
trial so when gina said yes she had she
had to be excused because of course
there was a formal witness sequestration
order in place meaning that these
witnesses can't hear any of the trial so
that's why she dismissed her from the
court and that is why all of her
testimony was excluded all right mike
we've heard the breakdown there from
terry now the question for you is do you
agree that her testimony should have
been completely excluded do you think
the judge maybe went a little too far
could there possibly have been a less
dramatic solution like a middle ground
here
i i'm sure there could be a debate about
that but quite frankly the sequestration
order is such a basic
sort of
logical step to keep trials as honest as
they could be where people are not
trying to make stories match other
witnesses it's very difficult people
don't realize as attorneys sometimes
when we call witnesses we can't discuss
what other witnesses testified with them
so i think the judge did the right thing
here and i don't think it would be of
any appellate or argument or value to
have left her on and try to clean it up
because i think it's better to remove
that testimony totally yeah it's all
moving chess pieces at this point when
it comes to witnesses but from what
we're hearing and i don't think jesse
heard it from the alpacas but deb may
actually testify on tuesday and and
that's going to be the big one too i
know you're laughing mike but the
alpacas can give him good information
sometimes and so if dep does testify i
think that's going to be the majority of
the case we'll see how that plays off
and of course give you updates here on
lawn crime daily and switching coasts
now to california as a woman formerly
pleads guilty to faking a 2016 abduction
sherry poppini pled guilty monday
morning in federal court on two charges
mail fraud and lying to an officer the
charges date back to november 2016 when
papini allegedly went missing 22 days
later she was found on an interstate
about 150 miles south from where she was
reported missing papini claimed two
hispanic women and a dark suv abducted
and tortured her her ex-boyfriend told
investigators papini actually stayed
with him during those three weeks and
that she inflicted those injuries
including branding herself on her own
papini was married with two children at
the time according to court documents
papini will pay more than three hundred
thousand dollars in restitution to the
agencies involved in the search for her
while prosecutors say they will
recommend reduced sentences the charges
could carry up to 25 years behind bars
but pina is said to be sentenced in june
coming up on law and crime daily after
days of deliberations jurors reach a
deadlock in ohio
plus far-right website infowars files
for bankruptcy as front man alex jones
faces multiple defamation suits our
legal analysis after the break
[Music]
welcome back a busy weekend for law
enforcement across the country as dozens
of people were injured in three mass
shootings over the easter and passover
weekend two in south carolina in the
third in pittsburgh two teenagers were
killed and at least eight others were
injured after a shooting at a party in
pittsburgh it happened at a home rented
through the short-term rental company
airbnb police say more than 90 shots
rang out early sunday morning at the
party attended by as many as 200 people
this came just a day after someone
opened fire at a busy mall in columbia
south carolina nine people were shot at
the crowded mall saturday and five
others were injured in a stampede during
the gunfire two people have been
arrested in connection to the shooting
marquis robinson and joayne price who is
on house arrest after making bail price
claims he shot his pistol in
self-defense he's been charged with
unlawfully carrying a firearm nine
people were injured in another shooting
sunday at a lounge hosting an easter
bash in south carolina no deaths have
been reported the three mass shootings
are just the latest string of a surge of
gun violence across the country
switching gears now far-right website
infowars files for bankruptcy amongst
admits defamation lawsuits stemming from
alex jones's comments about the sandy
hook school shooting jones the front man
behind the infowars site faces multiple
defamation suits for referring to the
school shooting as a hoax infowars and
two other companies owned by jones have
now filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
court documents show infowars states it
has assets of zero to fifty thousand
dollars with liabilities of one million
and one dollars to ten million dollars
all this comes as a judge rules jones
will recoup seventy five thousand
dollars originally paid in fines to a
connecticut court jones was initially
fined for not showing up to his
deposition but the money was ordered to
be returned after jones went to a
rescheduled deposition relatives of the
20 children and six educators killed in
the sandy hook massacre sue jones
claiming they've been harassed and have
received death threats from jones
followers anaga's court date is set for
that case to determine how much jones
owes in damages in a separate case out
of texas jones was found liable for
similar damages he's scheduled to be in
court for that case later this month
all right terry kind of just break it
down for us what does filing for
bankruptcy mean for jones in terms of
these civil suits
well jones actually filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy as far as infowars is
concerned and that was filed in texas
chapter 11 basically is putting whatever
pending civil litigation is going on on
hold so it gives the organization a
chance to reorganize essentially but
they can continue to operate and it's
often used by these big corporations to
help them stay in business so they will
pay their creditors back but it's going
to be on a very low percentage of what
was originally owed at least the hope is
that some of the monies will be paid
back but listen there are many
plaintiffs suing for defamation and if
in fact he says he has very little money
the percentage that they get will be
very little yeah and that's kind of what
i want to ask mike about because when we
look at the potential harm and the
damages for calling this massacre a hoax
how high could these damages be and do
we actually see these families
collecting every penny or is it
something else
well it's always difficult with class
action suits because the numbers may be
large when we look at them but when you
look at all the people who are members
of the class that are putting forth the
action
is the money is really not there for
them a lot of the money gets
in these huge cases gets eaten up by the
attorneys and the investigation one of
the things here too is let's not forget
when you file for bankruptcy you should
be very careful because those are
certified and you're swearing to the
truth of the things you're doing so if
people are looking for assets they may
go beyond this bankruptcy to see if this
in fact is a legitimate bankruptcy so he
may not be solving problems and he may
be creating others so it's very
complicated yes the age-old phrase of
it's not the crime it's the cover-up so
you're definitely expecting some of
these people to look into this
bankruptcy great point there mike
when we come back ohio versus william
husel after weeks of testimony and days
of deliberation jurors reach a deadlock
but does that mean a hung jury that's a
head on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily jurors
say they are at an impasse as
deliberations continue into day four
monday in the case of former icu
physician william husell an ohio doctor
accused of killing more than a dozen
patients over the course of three years
prosecutors say husso ordered lethal
doses of fentanyl to be administered to
patients from 2015 until 2018 at mount
carmel hospital in columbus ohio he
faces 14 murder charges his defense team
argues whoso was giving end of life
comfort care and not attempting to show
in the lives of his patients originally
the former doctor was charged in the
deaths of 25 patients but 11 of those
charges were dropped earlier this year
over the course of the week's long trial
jurors heard from several people who
worked alongside whoso and the family
members of the several alleged victims
on monday just before a court broke for
lunch the judge read what is called a
howard charge because the jury was
deadlocked the charge instructing the
jury to continue deliberations once they
returned if convicted whosoever faces
the possibility of life in prison jurors
can also consider a lesser offense of
attempted murder for each of the 14
counts the jury was sent home monday
afternoon after a verdict was still not
reached
mike i i don't know what it is but what
do you think the jury is stuck on in
deciding this case that's still having
them deliberate to another day
i think this jury is this jury is stuck
on the fact that there are no
professional standards that were
introduced to show that this doctor went
off the accepted science in his
field of medical care and i think that
really gives a lot of flexibility here
and the law shouldn't be
that flexible where it's so tough to
defend and i think that's really what
the jurors having a problem is at the
end of the day he really didn't put off
the inevitable and i think people are
saying he was aiding people that's an
interesting argument because if he's
convicted that argument could feed into
an appeal of unconstitutionally vague as
to the crime and based on what you're
saying he could win now terry who said
was charged with 14 counts of murder why
do you think the court allowed the
attempted murder charges to also be
added
you know it's very strange to me because
usually when you allow a lesser included
offense it's based on the evidence but
that lesser included offense and the
higher
offense basically have to have the same
element so you have something like a
manslaughter is a lesser included
offense of murder or an assault is a
lesser included offense of rape but here
it's very difficult to understand why
with the original charge of murder the
judge is going to allow the lesser
included of attempted murder because
obviously with attempted murder the
person doesn't die here's my guess i
think the only witness that came in for
the defense testified that essentially
in order to determine whether or not
these people died he thinks that it
wasn't because of the medication so
maybe that's the reason but yeah maybe
whosoever tried but he wasn't the cause
yeah we'll see well thank you for
joining us here on lawn crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you